[Applause]
so Laila we're on the set of your own
series home made simple which is I think
a far cry from the masked singer stage
so do the absolutely but you know what I
loved doing both just as much we know
you to be fearless I mean you've done a
lot of amazing things in your life in
your career but how did competing on the
masking or compared to being in the ring
oh my god you know what the only
comparison I can really make is that
moment when you're about to go out where
you kind of feel those butterflies but
you're just like with it I'm about to do
it you know you don't want to have any
regrets so you want to leave it all out
there and I feel like I did but you're
also competitive too so you were like
ready to win right oh I definitely well
you know I was ready to in my mind as an
athlete and as a champion I have certain
goals and my goal was to try to make it
far into the show I didn't really didn't
think I was gonna win you know you got
it you got to know your weight class
okay so I was like you know they might
have some real professional singers here
that's not my weight class
so there's 16 of them yeah yeah yeah but
that's not really my mind my lane but so
to speak but I definitely did not think
that I was gonna go home so soon for
sure I was like if you're gonna see me
in that outfit and that suit I was like
oh my god I want to cry so I had to like
yeah like my tears doesn't it help
though the fact that you are in a
costume with a huge mask you know like
because I don't know about you but I
sing in the car sing in the shower
that's it
like did you kind of live out a fantasy
being on the show absolutely lived out a
fantasy of wanting to get on a stage and
sing and it was great that no one knew
who I was at the same time it was tough
you know it's much harder to sing in
that suit more than I can imagine
because the mic is actually this far
away from my mouth so to learn how to
project your voice because I felt like I
could sing better when I was practicing
in the studio and when I got on the
stage like why do I sound like that but
I didn't have time was like you just
have to go you gotta go make it happen
okay see did you get enough rehearsal
time like cuz I assumed besides a dress
rehearsal you're trying to also get used
to performing in a mascot there's a
whole lot going over but you know
everyone got the same amount of
rehearsal time so I was like you know I
you know I would love to have my
conspiracy you have fun but I know it
wasn't easy keeping this a secret
because not even the contestants know
who's playing you know who in your
family or in your circle knew you're on
the show my husband knew okay
because I don't wanna think I was
cheating on him I mean like a good dad
yeah I want to private detective on me
so I was like look I'm doing the math
thing or okay don't tell anybody
yeah well we could not tell the kids and
then my manager of course because you
know somebody so now that the kids know
I'm assuming they know thank you you
know so did this kind of up the cool
factor for mom that performing on the
last thing you know we had some mixed
reaction they first of all super
embarrassed by me cuz I sing and they're
like stop stop stop dancing cuz I post
stuff on my social media page all the
time dancing in the kitchen they think
I'm crazy they think their mom is crazy
so when the show came on I was like we
got this really cool show we got a watch
and the only way I can really get them
into it that's like there might be some
youtubers or some gamers and then
someone got put off last week that was
actually you know a gamer yeah so they
so they believed me so we started
watching when I started singing they're
like that sounds like you mom I was like
how could that be me I'm sitting right
here and they were like is alive I'm
like yes lives but and I remember when
the mask came off their ID oh my god and
I actually recorded it with my phone and
then erased it but you'll remember that
forever that forever
absolutely also they recognize who you
were they knew my voice is pretty
distinct okay you know and that's why it
was really important for me to wear a
padded suit because I felt like about
what it came out one of the body suits
then people would have put it all
together it's not that many tall 511 you
know fine hollow like me out there that
have been like oh that's Layla that's
Layla right there and I'm muscular and
and to be fair robin thicke guess right
he said it was you before the
performance ever began what did you
think well I didn't hear him in a moment
okay but he should have stuck with it
right hey you know maybe he need to come
on Laila Ali lifestyle learn how to you
know get that mindset strong next time
commit he'd have been right commit baby
I love that any guesses who else is on
the show cuz you guys don't know they
better all be a whole lot better than me
or move minute I'll be waiting in the
parking lot I'm joking I'm just joking I
don't know I have no idea who was on but
it's exciting it'll be watching at the
end of my seat
knowing the stamina it takes do you
think there's another athlete there cuz
you know performing a mascot uniform is
next-level you know it does take a lot
of shrimp oh my god I have so much
respect for the craft because that was
hard but yeah there's probably some
other afters I mean Johnny Weir was on
you know it'd be nice to see what other
female athletes there are some athletes
last season the thing about athletes is
especially retired athletes we already
do what we love to do so now it's really
about what's fun you know what are you
passionate about what's gonna challenge
you and you just kind of you know have
the freedom to be able to do these
things I'm sure there's some other
athletes there hello they better not be
able to sing better than Calum yeah last
question you in the clue package you
said you're doing this for your dad
what would he make of you on that stage
on the messenger you know what I do for
my dad is I always stay authentic and
real and true to myself and do the best
that I absolutely can and represent the
oddly family and legacy will and I know
he's proud and he continues to be any
shining down watching on me so just in
general that's what I do for my dad and
I think that's what we should all do for
people we love is honor them and respect
yourself brave do you know you could
sing oh my family knows I got so many
more talents like I so many mom talent
she's not done either okay she's conga
[Music]